president Trump doubling down on his
criticism of NFL national anthem
protesters by defending the military and
the flag in the anthem and those who
keep us safe all while the Democrats the
liberal mainstream to destroy Trump
media they do what they always do what
are they doing making this about race
when it's not and that is tonight's very
important breaking news opening
monologue
[Music]
so first tonight I want to take a few
moments and I want to thank all of you
for your support and your loyalty last
night you did make this show number one
in cable by far you know there's a lot
of people in the mainstream media on the
left they want the voice of this show
silence they want your voices silenced
and by the way there are even efforts
this very day to silence a boycott and
they want to get me fired this threat is
very real here's the sad truth if you're
a conservative and I have a conservative
worldview well people in the media today
guess what there are people that are
paid a lot of money it well funded to
sit and watch every single second minute
of every single day in the hopes that I
say one word one phrase one sentence
that they deemed politically incorrect
and then they can use it to get me fired
now with that said every night I made a
promise last night to you we will not
stop on this program till my dying
breath as long as they'll have me to
give you news and strong opinion and
information you won't get anywhere else
we do hope that you and your friends
you'll tell your friends to join us
every single night we hope you'll set
your DVR again I thank you and now
tonight's top story president Trump is
refusing to back down he is now calling
out the NFL national anthem protesters
who are disrespecting the flag the
military in our country here's what the
president said earlier today in the Rose
Garden I was at Walter Reed Hospital
recently and I saw so many great young
people and their missing legs and their
missing arms and they've been so badly
injured and they were fighting for our
country they were fighting for a flag
they were fighting for our national
anthem and for people to disrespect that
by kneeling during the playing of our
National Anthem I think is disgraceful
I think
it's a very important thing for the NFL
to not allow people to kneel during the
playing of our National Anthem to
respect our country and to respect our
flag now the president is dead on when
it comes to this kneeling issue the
national anthem the flag it's about
saluting honoring our military remember
it was written after the Battle of Fort
McHenry and for all the president's
critics out there oh he shouldn't talk
about this he was right to call
attention to this issue
so all these NFL players coaches owners
the ones that are kneeling because of
apparent social injustice what a protest
the President himself or to raise
awareness for whatever other leftist
issues they may be promoting well I
don't make the argument they're
completely uninformed if they are about
inclusion and unity and understanding
then why don't they sit down with the
brave men and women who fought and bled
for this country maybe they should learn
why every American should proudly stand
for the flag for the star-spangled
banner why don't they talk to the
mothers and fathers I've interviewed
them who lost their sons and daughters
or why don't they talk to those who had
their limbs blown off fighting for this
country I'm pretty sure they'd be happy
to explain why people should in fact
stand this is about respect this is
about respect for the military for our
country for our flag and those who
fought under that flag it's plain and
simple which is why these acts of
protests are beyond disrespectful now if
some NFL players coaches owners you want
to keep doing it you go for it but
here's my prediction people are gonna
continue to change the channel and
they'll stay home on football Sunday and
like I said last night Saturday is now
my official football day unless and
until this is resolved and according to
The Wall Street Journal Direct TV is now
letting at least some customers cancel
subscriptions to its Sunday Ticket
package of NFL games and obtain refunds
if they cite players national anthem
protestors the reason also look what's
happening around the country look at
this people who spent hundreds and
hundreds of dollars on NFL memorabilia
they're burning their jerseys they were
the once prized possessions and
treasures they are that upset now while
President Trump is defending the flag
the military
Republicans like Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan will be on this show tomorrow
night or coming out and they are
supporting the president let's take a
look people are clearly within their
rights to express themselves how they
see fit my own view though is we
shouldn't do it on the anthem the
national anthem our flag and the people
who defend it and represent it that
should be celebrated everywhere in all
ways and that's my opinion and the
Attorney General jeff Sessions he's also
backing the president watch what he said
president United States has free speech
he believes and I believe that people
should take a moment before a football
game and stand when the national anthem
is played what's wrong with that it's
not political it's not an affirmation of
Trump or Hillary Clinton or any other
agenda is simply an affirmation respect
for the United States of America and
this great heritage of freedom and for
these football players prosperity that
they have so I think that's a perfectly
appropriate thing for the president to
say so taking a knee or stay in the
locker room during the national anthem
you know what that's pretty easy to do
addressing real problems that impact
real people and doing something about
that is a lot harder let's start by
helping the people we always talk about
the millions of forgotten men and women
in this country 50 million Americans in
poverty 50 million on food stamps 90
plus million Americans out of the labor
force the NFL you want to continue to
disrespect the country the military
well that's given players by the way and
owners the opportunity to make millions
and even in some cases billions of
dollars then it's time to stop taking
handouts from the American taxpayers I
doubt you'll hear this elsewhere in the
media let's look at the numbers the
average public subsidy for an NFL
stadium is 266 million taxpayer dollars
since the year 2000 it is estimated 3.2
billion dollars in federal taxpayer
money is gone to help build private
sports stadiums then you factor in local
and state funding for stadiums well that
number grows to 5.9 billion and
6.7 billion that's over just the last 20
years and if that's not shocking enough
well there's the NFL's pay patriotism
scandal there was a Senate report it
found that from the years 2012 to 2015
the Department of Defense they actually
paid the NFL 6.1 million dollars to
honor troops and for recruiting
promotions now the league did pay back
$700,000 of that but only after coming
under intense criticism what about the
rest of the money now those numbers are
astounding now if some in the NFL they
don't want to stand you don't want to
honor the flag the country the military
then stop taking all the money from the
American people because let's be honest
you know what they don't need it in the
NFL now while this national anthem issue
is clearly about respecting the military
the country our flag well the Democrats
members of the mainstream left-wing
establishment ideological media
predictably are trying to make this all
about race this is what they always do
it's part of their playbook I pointed
out so many times on this program every
two years every four years the
Democratic Party plays the race card
creating division and causing unrest in
the country and I played those spots and
thoughts over and over again and now
Democrats are doing the same thing with
the national anthem protest they are
also using this opportunity to attack
president Trump watch this from just two
prominent Democrats take a look she went
down to the Heart of Dixie in Alabama
before an all-white or mostly white
crowd the good ol boy so to speak and he
engaged in what many of us I think in
Fairley call race baiting the President
of the United States chose to pull the
sheets off and reveal himself in terms
of his tendency to be a racial arsonist
it's quite telling that he is willing to
attack black athletes he never says
anything of an insulting manner toward
white supremacist or neo-nazis or Ku
Klux planters or the I'm glad Amir Putin
right
and of course they destroy Trump
establishment media then not far behind
and echoing everything the Democrats say
all of their talking points take a look
if anyone actually believes this is
about the flag then you must believe
Rosa Parks protest was about a bus I
think he's playing along with white
identity politics and sort of white
grievance politics right we've heard
this language before from white people
in the deep south referring to
african-americans and especially black
athletes who they feel is taking their
place and so this wasn't a dog whistle
this was a bull horn but clearly it's
ethnic do you think it is and ethnic
enemies he has walked into a fight that
was about race and he knew it was about
race and there's no way you could call
it anything else so let me say it I want
to help him out he's a racist okay he
came proverbially as close as you could
possibly come to shouting in a rally the
n-word that's what he did down there
fake news conspiracy news and the left
is in a total frenzy over this and
they're desperately trying to score as
many cheap political points as possible
Democratic lawmakers Maxine Waters Al
Green they're actually calling for
president Trump's impeachment over his
NFL comments really watch this insanity
he started dog whistling to that
constituency doing the campaign and
started his division and don't forget
balance said when it's about race we win
because they frighten people they play
into racism I hope people understand
it's about all of this that he should
not be the President of the United
States of America and we got to get
ready for impeachment mr. speaker I
denounced the comments that were made
and I rise to announce that on next week
Mr Speaker I will bring a privileged
resolution before the Congress of the
United States of America I will stand
here in the well of the Congress and I
will call for the impeachment of the
President of the United States of
America so pathetic so predictable two
Democrats they even took a knee on the
House floor as a show of solidarity with
the NFL pro
testers let's watch this you tell me
which of those children's mothers or a
son of a B that is racism you cannot
deny it you cannot run for it and I
kneel in so I joined so many now in the
NFL and elsewhere and taking a knee for
the America that we all aspire it to be
so the Democrats fake moral outrage it
knows no bounds they will literally do
and say anything to try and damage and D
legitimize president Trump they've been
doing that since last November and that
includes playing the race card every
single chance they get now even though
President Trump has explicitly said that
it's criticism of the NFL has nothing to
do with race it's about patriotism and
it should be obvious to everyone except
of course those that want to play the
race card like they do every two and
four years president Trump never
mentioned race when he called out the
NFL because it has nothing to do with
race and since Democrats that claiming
President Trump is trying to create a
racial divide in this country well we
have to ask where was the outrage when
President Obama was jumping to
conclusions without any facts or
information high profile race cases in
this country and saying outrageous
things that did have an impact on the
public you may remember this the
Cambridge police acted stupidly there is
a long history in this country of
african-americans and Latinos being
stopped by law enforcement
disproportionately and that's just a
fact
when Trayvon Martin was first shot I
said that this could have been my son
another way of saying that is that
Trayvon Martin could have been me 35
years ago and we have to close the
justice gap how justice is applied but
also how it is perceived how it is
experienced that's what we saw in
Ferguson this summer when Michael Brown
was killed and the community was divided
stains the heart of black children who
feel as if no matter what he does he'll
always be under suspicion brush
judgments rushing to judgment no
evidence no belief that somebody's
innocent until they're proven guilty we
can go back even further to Barack
Obama's book dreams of my father the
media never pointed it out we did where
he quoted the Reverend from the Church
of Gd America Jeremiah Wright listened
to well then candidate Obama saying this
it is this world a world where cruise
ships throw away more food in a day than
most residents of port-au-prince see in
a year where white folks greed runs a
world in need apartheid in one
hemisphere apathy in another hemisphere
these are things you'll never hear and
see from members of the mainstream media
because you know what they're so
abusively
biased and corrupt by the way they want
a silence shows like this and they work
hard at it for example where was the
left
rushing to condemn those comments he
wasn't a candidate but he was in
politics they didn't do it because
playing the race card dividing the
country along racial lines is how
Democrats think they need to winning it
votes you know what they just do
whatever they want they're never gonna
change
sadly because it's not good for the
country but people I think now are on to
their game it's getting old it's pretty
disgusting so tonight we have a
challenge for the left instead of you
trying to take down President Trump
24/7 365 exploiting this NFL issue why
don't you stand up for things that
matter our country our flag our brave
men and women who fight and bleed and
die for all of our freedoms